joining me now former speaker the house
fox news contributor newt gingrich he's
also the author of the upcoming book
defeating big government socialism
available for pre-order now
newt um
so
those people who are crowing the most
about this kind of this tenuous grasp on
democracy are the ones working the
hardest to undermine it
well let me say first of all i thought
your opening monologue was
beyond terrific i thought you
captured exactly where we are not just
here but around the world the whole
effort by the elites to hold on to power
no matter what i mean look here's the
core problem for the democrats
they apparently have signaled that they
know in advance that tomorrow's
inflation numbers are going to be
staggering
uh they have this game where they talk
about it being putin's price hike nobody
believes that
and so they've got average everyday
voters whether they're african-american
latino
white asian it doesn't matter they're
going to the gas station they're trying
to buy fill up their tank the last time
i did it with calista was 92 dollars
they're then going to the grocery store
they're trying to buy groceries
everything's more expensive and
i don't care how the democrats message
it
how are you going to get people to be
more frightened
of some theoretical problem you know
donald trump in 2024
then the reality that people are
watching the system breakdown they're
watching 18 000 people a day projected
to come across the southern border
that's the city of atlanta every single
month
they're watching rising crime rates
rising carjackings and they're looking
around thinking
none of this is working so the democrat
problem is you can't scare people enough
with some political theory when they're
already being frightened
by the reality you've created
now to your point about this this
messaging newt uh msnbc decided to drag
out i think new york city's worst mayor
to offer his um trench and perspective
on it watch
joe biden is a good messenger he is you
can relate to him across the ideological
spectrum he actually has the ability to
reach everyday working people
but what we're not hearing is a message
if i asked you around the table what's
the democratic message right now half
year out from an election
i don't know what that message is
newt i i i i'm gonna i'm gonna like just
burst out laughing on national tv
because they actually think they have a
messaging problem they don't think
there's a substitute
that is
that is such a low blow
i can't believe you did that bill de
blasio is arguably the worst mayor in
the history of new york
now i think it's fair to say biden is
working his way towards being the worst
president in history united states and
certainly i think kamala harris has
already won the award as the dumbest
person ever elected vice president but
to bring bill de blasio out
to defend joe biden i think is just
cruelty
no newt it's great to see you tonight as
always and i look forward to reading
your book oh wait i have time for one
more question they say i have time
oh
yes and newt your new book this is what
i wanted to ask you about the screen
went blank but it's coming out in
just a short while
young people especially
i think need to read this book because
all they hear in school too often is
that government will take care of the
problem if we only had more government
spending we'll save the plan if we only
so
why is this important now
well it's important because when we did
some work on the american majority
project we found that if you pitted free
market capitalism against big government
socialism it was 59 to 16 if people are
given a choice and if you ask swing
voters it was 82 to 18 and the reason is
young people who might have said well
socialism sounds good when you put big
government with socialism they go are
you crazy because they have a pretty
good idea big government just doesn't
work it's a huge amount of money huge
bureaucracies and very little product
and i think in that sense big government
socialism is the beginning of the end of
the democratic party as a serious
competitor yeah let's see if the
national librarians association actually
gets your book in the in the school
libraries parents should lobby to make
that happen that's what they that's what
needs to happen newt thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else